Imagine an alien civilization
is looking up at the night sky
scanning the heavens,
trying to detect signs of life.
We as a species have been sending
out radio signals for about 100 years
and we have followed that up
with television signals.
Those signals have gone into space
and travelled at the speed of light
and by now have reached
hundreds of stars
and hundreds of planets around them.
So if there was an alien civilization
in that distance
and they were pointing their
detectors roughly in our direction
they would have heard
the first BBC broadcasts,
and by now they would have seen
many, many years of Coronation Street
and have a rough idea
of how our humanity works.
Some very prominent scientists
think it's quite silly
that we're sharing quite so much
about ourselves to the galaxy.
Aliens may not be very kind
and maybe we shouldn't
be giving away our position
and our entertainment choices.
Maybe we should all just collectively
stop advertising ourselves
to the galaxy.
So imagine
that same alien civilization
looking at the night sky
but now there are no radio signals,
no television signals,
just 300 billion beautiful white
lights, quietly shining away.
But it is the white light,
seemingly so fundamental and pure,
that holds the key
to unlocking the secrets
of all those planets
around all those stars.
White light is only pure
until you crack it open.
With a prism or a drop of water,
white light shows
what really is within it.
The rainbow. And the rainbow isn't
just made up of seven colours.
With a powerful enough prism
you can get all of the reds
and all of the violets,
all of the infinite colours
between them and beyond them,
in the infrared and the ultraviolet.
So if that alien civilization pointed
their very expensive prism at our sun
they'll be able to see
our sun's rainbow.
And if they were very patient
and looked carefully
they would notice that every year
a few new shadows would appear
and then disappear.
And they would appear and disappear.
And those shadows are caused
by the molecules in our atmosphere.
And they will be able to look at
those shadows in the rainbow
and know that we have
an extremely lively planet.
That we have vast inhabited oceans,
that we're oxygen reliant lifeforms,
that we have at least one
technological species
and also that we pollute a lot.
The Earth has a living atmosphere -
we call that a biosphere -
and that biosphere is a planet-sized,
unintentional message
to any aliens out there
that care to listen.
It tells the story of who lives on
this planet and what we do with it.
So we could stop
sending messages into space
but even if we do go quiet,
they can still tell we're here.
It's the galactic equivalent
of thinking "I'm invisible now".
Well we can already look
at some alien atmospheres,
although we can't quite look
at a full terrestrial atmosphere yet,
but we're very close.
At MIT, I develop the tools
to try to decipher
these potential alien biospheres.
Those tools are how I will be
listening in to alien messages.
And of course I would love to receive
the alien version of The Simpsons
coming down from the heavens.
Until then I will be looking
for the signs of life
that the aliens
didn't even mean to create.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)